I hate about the NFL nobody picks up the
phone over
there they're screening my calls every
week when I
whine they no they see the number they
go dude don't get that one dude don't
get that don't get that one he's a
terrible Gambler and he's gonna blame us
again just funny he thinks it's
fixed there's literally 50 guys on both
[__] Sidelines he thinks they're all
involved and they keep their mouth shut
that field goal miss is she's taking it
out on you he's asking about the prevent
defense again I I mean I can't I can't
if if you want if you want to take the
call you take the call what's he going
to do talk about the flight gate again
no there's a phone line there's a phone
for everyone but then the bill bur phone
is
red the red one's blinking just says do
not answer on top blinking dude the red
was blinking which kicker missed he what
else is no they're trying to find most
these [__] just call Sunday night
this [__] jerk off's calling us on a
Tuesday